he is president of every single American
he's not my president he's not the
president of a lot of people my
expectation number one is that he's
going to be on Twitter all the time
because that seems to be his propaganda
tool freedom of the press freedom of
speech are going to be destroyed I don't
want to be a failure I wanted to really
really succeed i wanted to do great
things the holidays house in berlin's
courts burg district is a meeting place
for American expats almost 17,000
Americans live in the German capital but
it's hard to find many Trump supporters
here why is that living in Berlin you
have to be a little bit adventurous and
open and I think most Trump supporters
are really close mine and uneducated I
think expats tend to be very liberal
people who also openly take issues with
things in their own country and that's
why they leave it you see a lot of
Americans here that come from big cities
like New York Los Angeles Chicago and
those are the places that obviously
always leaning democratically Gillian
may founded the hot ashes house with two
business partners along with the
lunchroom there's an old fashioned
general store offering a mix of products
response to the u.s. election results
has been mixed among Americans in Berlin
it's not that anyone's planning a huge
revolution but people are definitely
aware and they're they're cautiously
observing what's happening and trying to
figure out how to how to move on may
says that Donald Trump selection doesn't
affect her directly but that it will
have repercussions for us cultural
institutions
it's going to be hard for these
institutions to consistently get funding
the funding that they need I think that
the arts and culture is something that
Trump is not so concerned about and
wouldn't that be something if the
president actually is somebody who
secretly loves the arts secretly loves
the theater and music I'm he lives just
down the street from Broadway Alexander
Frei is an organist pianist and
conductor who's worked with orchestras
around the globe born in Chicago he
supports the Democrats and knows what he
wants from the new president universal
healthcare for everyone like Canada has
perhaps a great defense for the country
strong defense protecting us against
terrorism and protecting American
interest throughout the world a sound
economic and trade policy so that
everybody in the United States has a job
and has good living and that the quality
of life for every American is raised
they have not reached out to people like
us like me they haven't reached out to
anyone who would fall under any of the
categories of what I would fall under to
comp to make us feel better to say that
we're not going to be excluded that
we're not going to be we're not going to
end up in internment camps or we're not
going to lose our livelihoods Diana arse
is an American artist and activist who
lives in Berlin one of her projects is
well he's out okay that's like carioca
in which the audience Reese Peaks
speeches from politicians she wants to
sensitize people to their rhetoric and
fears the worst for her country I'm safe
here but I can I know people who are in
the United States who don't agree with
this who are afraid to say something
because they know that they will make
themselves a target and this is this is
the kind of environment that's being set
up right now and if he continues being
our president it's only going to
escalate it's only going to get worse
eugene hasta chefs key is a writer and
literature professor at New York
University who currently lives in Berlin
born in Russia he moved to the US as a
child he sees many parallels between
Donald Trump and Vladimir Putin when
there's some kind of a fight with a
celebrity right the point of that fight
is so that everybody writes about it so
that they don't write about something
else okay and they think much about
Trump's focusing on celebrity critics or
in politician critics I think it's done
to hide other things if you want to
fight Trump you need to develop a a
political language for fighting Trump
you need to develop the proper way to
humiliate him the proper way to slur
against them my big hope for president
Trump is that he can somehow make people
feel secure in their everyday lives I
think a lot of what we've accomplished
in the last 40 50 years in terms of
women's rights civil rights it's going
to go back a couple of steps